a five on three late in regulation and
surrendering an early goal for or late
goal rather from Mason McTavish
here's Smith driving one and
score Riley Smith over the line he's got
Malin finds him drops it for rust cross
ice Pon centering and they score get an
offensive zone shift and some momentum
rust Barrels in after the puck centers in
front deflected and they score he let him
free like that with a little chip to speed I
like uh the chances of Russ getting to those
pucks H throws a puts it in Adam hurdle down low
gives him a nice option as we saw there penguins
control off the draw cross it comes the m and a
shot scores and how about the courtesy of Riley
Smith I'll finish that in a second here's Crosby
stepping ahead of the pack drops it for L Tank
backhander scores creating some chances here
in the offensive zone penguins have a chance
here it's nto two onone with aari feeds him
aari shooting and save rebound they score lost
the handle comes back to Carlson steps away
from zland gensel down low rust backhander
scores Raquel gets it free back to the point
Joseph One Touch to lat Tang Raquel smacks
it to Smith in front Malin slams it in P go
right back to work gensel in front a redirect
and R chance was denied it's loose it's in
they got a show from their guys tonight you
make it out once a year Josh you got to see
a lot and a Victorious and emphatic start to
this California trip as the Penguins stop the
San Jose Sharks 10 to2 their most goals since
putting 11 past the Detroit Red Wings in March of
2022 a lot of Feelgood to this one tonight Army